sous quel thé vert shia canneberges et
curcuma tous ont eu leur moment de
gloire en recevant le titre de super
aliment soit disant doté de pouvoirs
extraordinaires
l'adjectif super ça veut dire quelque
chose de remarquable quelque chose qui
est au delà des attentes et
ben chaplin aliments qui n'ont pas
la belle sur leurs étiquettes qui sont
quand même des éléments vraiment
intéressant le teos père el himma et
j'irais plutôt galvaudé pour le
marketing et non pas pour la recherche
[Musique]
des aliments qui étaient parfois
inconnus deviennent tout à coup les
vedettes des livres de recettes dans
tous les médias et sur les blogs
alimentaire dès qu'on veut mousser un
produit on engage des blogueurs qui
adapte un buzz qui se crée autour de
certains aliments
les médias font partie de ce buzz là
superfruits super serial super crack là
qu'est ce qu'un aliment doit avoir pour
être placé sur un piédestal
je pense qu'il doit être à la mode il
doit être un peu exotique donc venir de
loin parce que ça ajoute une petite
touche peut-être
intrigante mais c'est vrai que il doit
avoir des propriétés nutritives
intéressante peut-être pas exclusive
mais quand même intéressant il ya des
éléments qui sont meilleurs pour la
santé que d'autres mais de là à dire que
des éléments qui sont super donc on à la
connotation miracle un peu je pense que
c'est un peu idéaliste et ils topic de
penser ça
à l'institut de nutrition et d'aliments
fonctionnels on s'intéresse aux composés
spécifiques de certains aliments et de
leurs effets sur la santé oms ni souvent
exposés à des recherches qui existent
bon on a isolé la molécule dans le sirop
d'érable ou dans les pots de yogourt ou
dans un produit quelconque un effet sur
la santé des fois ci des issues des
études chez l'animal cd droz extrêmement
élevés pour essayer d'isoler les faits
on est très loin de la réalité du
consommateur qui va prendre une fois de
temps en temps par une fois par semaine
dans son alimentation
[Musique]
pour le consommateur et pour sa santé il
ya une poutre de garantie après vent si
on prend le quai puis qu'on lui met là
que l'éthique est super aliments il ya
zéro garantie qu'en mangeant ce jeu
répond le cancer où je répond à un
problème de santé cardiovasculaire
s'il ne possède pas de pouvoirs magiques
certains industriels récupère l'idée de
super aliments pour vanter leurs
produits
le mot super il peut être mis à toutes
les sauces j'ai vu des bonbons avec
super fruits ça reste un bon ben on l'a
quand même que vous l'avez aromatisée
avec de la saillie ou avec du goji ou de
ce que vous voudrez
l'idée du super animaux ça ne date pas
d'hier la banane a eu aussi son moment
de gloire quand on a commencé à manger
des bananes en amérique du nord au début
du 20e siècle les ventes à laymont
moyennement bien et oyonnax et type
fraude qui était la compagnie qui
exploitaient des bananeraies en amérique
centrale
1-1 décidé de prendre cette stratégie de
faire de la banane espèce de super
aliments donc on a commencé à dire
manger des bananes parce que elles n'ont
pas de germes
à la base de la promotion d'un super
aliments il faut avoir des études qui
vont prouver des choses et c'est ce
qu'avait fait l'industrie de la banane
en finançant des chercheurs pour aller
trouver des vertus à la banane qui
aurait un gros ménage à faire le dans
l'étiquette parce que le problème c'est
que l'industrie certains
industriels récupère ce terme là pour le
mettre sur leur emballage et ça laisse
supposer que leur produit est supérieur
et c'est souvent paul qu
on s'est amusé avec hélène laurendeau a
écrit petit déjeuner avec hills en
superlatifs
le déjeuner normale du gruau des petits
fruits une banane une belle orange
plutôt que le jus puis un produit
laitier ici là on est vraiment bien
nourrie on beaucoup beaucoup de bons
éléments nutritifs on n'est même pas
besoin besoin de deux mètres de quais là
dedans ça c'est complet mais ici j'ai
des supers grainger déçu par les
aliments à super smoothie alors ici
super faible en oui c'est ce que de tous
les pots super alors quand il ya le
moose super sur un emballage ça nous
enlève pas notre devoir d'aller lire la
liste des ingrédients
parce que côté d'un super ingrédients à
la mode il peut avoir du sucre est pas
avoir de l'huile végétale il peut avoir
des a et des érables il n'y a rien de
mal aujourd'hui à ne manger aucun de ces
super aliments puis a acheté simplement
des carottes du chou rouge du brocoli
des choses qui sont bien connues des
produits locaux pourquoi on irait manger
des fruits exotiques qui est dont on
sait même pas trop l'origine alors
qu'ici on a des pommes on a des prunes
on aime beaucoup de choses qu'on peut
qu'on peut acheter est-ce que c'est
l'effet baby boomer on vit plus vieux on
veut être éternelle et on veut dont se
faire du bien avec des super rallye
maths
effet mode ou marketing les
superaliments ne possède peut être pas
tout seul et pouvoir espérer mais s'ils
nous incitent à consommer plus de fruits
et de légumes alors ça c'est vraiment
super
[Musique]